Oliver's facing life in prison all rise
the People vs Oliver Jonas Queens when
you take this stand you're gonna be the
final nail in the car
I might be going to prison who is the
green arrow arrow all new this Thursday
at 9:00 8:00 central on the CW hey
everybody it's Charlie this is gonna be
mine on infinity war video for Friday
like there's literally almost nothing
going on besides infinity war but they
just dropped this huge teaser for the
arrow finale Colin Donnell wearing the
arrow costume like we've made all kinds
of funny posts about it the other day
when they posted it because Stephen
Amell just wrapped the arrow finale
himself and you can see that they're
giving him this buzz cut the title of
the finale is called life sentence so I
think that the finale in like some of
the stuff that they're putting together
here is a big teaser for what's actually
happening in season seven it cost me to
completely change my theory about what's
going on so I'll talk about that in a
second but let's talk about the finale
first and what's going on with Tommy if
you're finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
yes it's mostly infinity war for the
next couple of weeks as I'm posting this
video obviously like that's dominating
everything but between that we still
have a lot of finales that are happening
between flash and arrow so the big thing
with the arrow finale is is that it
talks a little bit about Oliver's trial
because like DSS why don't we move your
trial up a week so like they're gonna be
gonna be addressing that in next week's
episode he knows all the judges it's
very clear that he intends to throw
Oliver in prison for 25 to life so this
past week's episode was really just
about getting Anatoly back on his side
there was a check in with the new
recruits let's see what they're up to
but really this is all about
Diaz trying to throw all of her in
prison and what I think they're gonna be
doing for the first half at least of
season 7 so with Stephen Amell teased a
while ago that his haircut would be
completely different at the beginning of
season 7 naturally I was thinking the
van Dijk that a little while ago he made
an ambiguous funny Instagram post about
having to delay a certain promise that
he made and then he had posted a video
that someone had posted of him getting
really meta hear of him talking about
the van Dijk at a convention and he was
just saying that you know before the end
of the show before the series is done at
some point you'll see Oliver with that
classic Van Dyke so he was just
basically saying that whenever they do
cancel arrow at some point before that
he
have the van Dijk but based on what it
seems like they're teasing for season
seven that's not gonna happen
during season seven so here's the new
theory first half of season seven is
Oliver Queen in prison and if you've
been a longtime fan of the Green Arrow
character and you've been following a
lot of the DC movies from the early to
mid-2000s that didn't get made there's
that George Miller Justice League movie
that almost got made there's the Kevin
Smith Superman movie that almost got
made there was also a Green Arrow movie
in development back in 2008 with David
Goyer and Justin marks so it'd be Oliver
Queen in prison for a crime that he did
not commit falsely accused but having to
fight his way out across a gauntlet of B
and C lists super villains
from the DC Universe like Escape from
Alcatraz Arkham style within the DC
Universe remember just a little while
ago there was a Batman movie that Ben
Affleck was gonna star and that he and
Geoff Johns wrote that was gonna be him
fighting his way through Blackgate
prison across all the DC characters so
it's kind of like arrow doing a version
of the Green Arrow movie Stephen Amell o
is teased that they might do a Green
Arrow movie at some point even Marc
Guggenheim but no idea what that would
be like this actually Oliver Queen in
prison is a lot easier for them to do
because you remember Barry being in
prison for a couple of episodes of the
flash this season comfortable
imagine a whole half season to that
HBO's Oz with the green arrow character
now who would appear in prison with him
like which other big DC characters would
be in there with him we don't know they
haven't announced any of that stuff yet
but of all the theories that I've had
about season 7 this is the cheapest for
them to do and because arrows getting on
in seasons is a little harder for them
to do like really big sweeping stuff
they don't do a lot of special effects
prison is a genre in a setting that's
very endemic to the stuff that era
already does crime drama so naturally
doing half a season with Oliver in
prison in Supermax makes a lot of sense
but I know there's all kinds of
questions about what's gonna happen with
Diaz and why is Tommy wearing the green
arrow costume like they'll have a legit
doppelganger show up when it comes to
Tommy related stuff on arrow I always
try to keep my expectations low because
he's still a main cast member on his
other doctor show so his availability is
really low so when they use him it's
usually very brief but it just sounds
like this episode is him coming from
another earth because it's physical
Tommy trying to take the fall as the
green arrow the same way that Roy did so
many seasons ago like he can't be the
green arrow because I'm the green arrow
the question is is which earth did he
come from because I don't remember them
ever telling us what happened to Earth
to Tommy we know that earth to Oliver
was believed to have died in the Queen's
Gambit and then his father Robert Queen
became the green arrow during flash
season two because black siren is such a
big part of this trial then they might
use her Tommy from Earth - so just big
question about how he got from Earth to
where all these criminals coming from
because zoom was the one that was
opening portals during flash season two
that allowed black siren to get to earth
one
us to this new world ours for the taking
whose world is this
but maybe they'll have some funny line
of dialogue they tend to not explain
stuff like that on arrow as much because
it's not a science-based show but even
though Tommy seems like he's showing up
to do this the title of the finale
remember is life sentence implying that
this trial situation is gonna spill over
into the finale so it's not like they're
gonna completely wrap everything up so
we'll see how it all goes down and don't
forget about the crossover next year so
there's just like a certain timeline
based on network television and how it's
plotted out like it would still be kind
of weird for Oliver to be in prison
during the big crossover episode because
it's gonna be the Flash's 100th episode
remember what they did for arrows 100th
episode It's a Wonderful Life arrow
style with those characters they brought
back Robert Queen Moira queen they did
this whole alternate life thing just
expect them to do something similar with
the flash with a pay homage to the
really big story arcs that they've done
the last couple of years it'll probably
be mostly flash centric and I'm hoping
they do some flash family stuff but I'll
be interested to see how they integrate
that episode with the other episodes of
the crossover because now it's almost
like a four hour movie so it's a little
harder for them to do a self-contained
flash story within that but I'm sure
we'll hear more about that at Comic Con
because they did say that they started
planning next year's crossover in the
last couple of weeks like right now
they're talking about how they're gonna
structure the crossover what the basic
framework is gonna be then they'll start
writing it soon and then by the time we
get to October they'll be shooting it so
if you remember all the behind the
scenes that we got last year for the big
crossover it'll be just like that
this fall but what will happen next is
is I'll be posting my full infinity war
review we'll talk about everything
there'll be a big spoiler warning at the
beginning of that there'll be a whole
bunch more infinity war happening this
weekend so don't worry we'll talk about
everything because there is a lot to
unpack but click here for my infinity
war post-credit scene video and click
here for brand new flash thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight